[Music]
hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about a prophecy of the drunkard
raising an Australian Targaryen that is
yet to be fulfilled Game of Thrones is
coming to its end
April 2019 incident we'll be seeing the
final six episodes of the show which are
said to be extra long and sure to be
jam-packed with an action the series has
been building - what makes Game of
Thrones one of the best shows ever is
its unpredictability no one is safe but
at the same time old events have been
held for shadow'd which you only know
what is supported watching it multiple
times and after the four share of event
has already happened when you watch
other TV shows you might assume that the
main character will make it out alive
and the table will be defeated
more or less yet with Game of Thrones
things don't always turn out this way
Simon Ramsay Bolton once told Theon if
you think this has a happy ending you
have not been paying attention he wasn't
lying
that said fans had and still in fact
helped plenty time to rewatch the show
countless times and try to find every
little hint that might be for sharing
some of the main characters tragic fate
in fact fans already did find some major
he is possible for sharing Johnston's
fate it's an already mentioned prophecy
of Jon God raising a destroyed egg and
Targaryen the drunk guy represents ruin
gradually and he will in season a
destroy Aegon Targaryen Jon Snow or
least in this theory prophecies visions
and dreams considering the past present
or future form an important part of
narrative in Song of Ice and Fire novels
many of them were omitted from the game
of thrones TV series although several
have gradually been introduced
George Arman has pointed out that the
prophecies are often so vague that they
can frequently be interpreted in
contradictory ways to the point that
they're not useful as a guide future
save for the meanings that the people
themselves supply to their words as
Martin said himself prophecy is a staple
element in fantasy but it's tricky you
want to play with the notion of prophecy
is coming true but in an unexpected way
you want to be unpredictable about it
with that in mind let's continue with
the theory in season 7 episode 5
archmaester eyebrows and the other main
search discuss brain starts later
warning that the knight Kings armies
marching south towards
eastwatch-by-the-sea he and other
masters are skeptical of this report and
dismiss scimitars efforts to vouch for
brain Evers himself things that letter
could be this information spread by a
self-proclaimed Queen Daenerys Targaryen
they agreed to investigate his claims
and sent a letter to Winterfell
inquiring into brains claims however the
most interesting part happens when Sam
leaves the room and the main stars start
discussing or should I say making fun
prophecies one of them being the
prophecy of lordose which says that
young God will rise up in defeat a gun
in case you don't remember this let's
take a look I promise you we will get to
the truth of it one way or another arch
mr. Mayall Talia brings to mind work who
TV those stones the charlatan who
claimed descent from the children of the
sorrows forget the dogs who promised
that the drowned God would rise up and
destroy Aegon the conquerer the drowned
God will rise up and straig and conquer
the prophecy claimed in this theory the
prophecy was not wrong but was
misinterpreted about the wrong Hagen in
season seven it was revealed that John
Stone is actually Aegon Targaryen in
episode 5 of the same season similarly
overheard the minister discuss a
prophecy from lordos death the jungle
returned to destroy Aegon the conquerer
young Rachel refers to himself as the
jungle at multiple times
that's the custom change since I've been
gone aren't you supposed to repeat the
words I am to drown God so we kept John
snow whose real name is Aegon Targaryen
we also have you on great jerk-off
reversed himself as the drunk God and
the troll we also received the null
prophecy of the drunk erasing a
destroyed Aegon Targaryen that is yet
unfulfilled it could just be a throwaway
line or you could foreshadow one of the
finales biggest and most shocking
moments all of this led some fans to
conclude that urine will be the one to
destroy John in the end the theory has
mixed feelings
some fans can see this happen and would
not be disappointed with the show
well errors Canton would be pretty
disappointing the descent for Jon Snow
some say they could see John dying after
he's defeated the night king and after
he's got any pregnant with the Targaryen
child so basically as long as John's
line is continued and as long as John's
done his part in the great for some fans
would be ok with it other users point
out they would be disappointed if this
theory was to come true since gern is a
minor character to take down John -
their response supporters of this theory
point out that the show often pulls this
move Eddard Stark was beheaded as a
traitor by a boy king and John's love
Ygritte was shut down by a young child
with a bow and arrow bore ended story of
King Robert as one fan explained once
his purpose is complete I think anything
can end him if there's no more story to
tell they could face any possible end no
matter how big their character is these
feelings kind of match it what game of
turn start said about its ending many
will be happy with it many will not
sophie turner and extras the portray
sense of star head is to say about the
game terms final season I think a lot of
fans will be disappointed and a lot of
fans will be over the moon in my opinion
urine rager will be one of the biggest
villains of the final season right
behind Cersei and the night King will he
be the one to put an end to Jon Snow
story I do believe that the prophecy of
the jungle raising and destroying Aegon
Targaryen will be fulfilled in season 6
urine says multiple times that he's a
John God incident 7 we hear about his
prophecy and in season 7 finale we learn
Joshua name is Aegon I believe that in
his prophecy the jeonga represents your
own rager
and he will in season a destroy Aegon
Targaryen Jon Snow although I believe
that this prophecy will come true
I don't believe urine will destroy Jon
Snow literally as most prophecies never
come true literally how I see this
prophecy happening is you're destroying
egg and in terms of
hello yours arm evil story Jones army
and urine might even take a hostage but
he will most certainly not be the one to
put an end to Jon Snow at least in my
opinion the next popular theory I'm
going to talk about in this video is
about the dragon being underneath
Winterfell some fans of Game of Thrones
believe that a little dragon is living
underneath the star castle of Winterfell
deep within the crypts we already know
the crypts of interval are huge and full
of mystery but containing dragon does
seem unbelievable or at least at first
once you actually start digging in turns
out where there's smoke there's fire let
me give you a quick summary of all the
evidence that let people think there
might be a dragon of interval the
ancestral seat of House Stark is built
directly over Hot Springs here's a quote
about it from a game of Thrones the
Catelyn to chapter the castle had been
built over natural hot springs and a
scalding water rush through its walls
and chambers like blood to a man's body
during the chill from the stone holes
filling the glass gardens with a moist
warmth keeping the earth from freezing
open pool smoke day and night in a dozen
small courtyards there was a little
thing in summer in winter it was the
difference between life and death these
Hot Springs are heated the maser say by
the furnaces of the world which appear
only in two other places in the entire
world both of those places are
associated with you guessed it Dragons
here's the description for the world of
Ice and Fire and in universe history
book that presents the expansive
backstory of the known world of Westeros
and beyond the Winterfell chapter Hot
Springs such as the one beneath
Winterfell have been shown to be heated
by the furnace of the world the same
fires that made the fourteen flames saw
the smoking Mountain American stone if
you don't know the fourteen flames are
located in malaria where dragons were
first discovered and Dragonstone is
where the Targaryen sleep before Aegon
the conquerer decided to invade all of
Westeros as it turns out it's not only
fans who believe there might be a dragon
underneath Winterfell
it's also the small folk of Winterfell
who feel the same both the small folk of
Winterfell and the small folk of winter
town a town located just outside of
Winterfell itself have been known to
claim that the spring stir heated by the
breath of a dragon that sleeps beneath
the castle and the small folk are not
the only ones who speak of gigantic
Tevere below of interval mushroom hooves
the court fool for some very important
Targaryen also thought there was a
dragon activity below the castle as
mushroom was the court fool and a dwarf
people believed him to be a liquid
causing nobles to speak more freely
around him mushrooms testimony was
written down by an unknown writer the
account is filled with mushrooms tale
subplots that
twists and debouch rates among other
things the story is starring the most
explicit detail except the news desk has
written an account the reign of king
Missouri's first of his name and the
dance of the Dragons that came after
covering many of the same women they're
described in mushrooms account and fell
off and the two disagree on how events
occurred at times they do agree copies
of the testimony of mushroom were burned
on orders of King Baylor the first
Targaryen although some have survived to
be referred to in archmaester gil Danes
histories the testimony of mushroom
allege that the Prince Jake here is
valerian came to Winterfell at the start
of the dance of the Dragons ver mcslade
dragon eggs in the depths of the crypts
were hot springs their near divorce arch
mr. Gil Dana rejects the idea here's one
quote about his claim from the world of
Ice and Fire we can dismiss mushrooms
claim in his testimony that the dragon
remains left a clutch of eggs somewhere
in the depths of Winterfell scripts
heard waters of the Hot Springs run
close to the walls while his rider
treated with Greg and stark at the start
of the dance of the Dragons remember
that the world of Ice and Fire is
written as history from a single masters
perspective so just because that
particular Meister dismisses mushrooms
claim doesn't mean that it's not true
all of this brings us to something quite
peculiar that happens in the books when
Winterfell is burned down by Ramsay
Bolton at the time of the fire brainy's
walked into his direwolf who is in the
godswood on Winterfell
there is their wolf's eyes brain sees
what appears to be a dragon this is
described in Clash of the Kings in the
branch 7 chapter the smoke and ash cloud
is ice and in sky he saw a great fing
snake whose roar was a river of flame he
bared his teeth but then the snake was
gone there's been some debate among the
readers as to exactly what brain saw in
the sky some believed that it was simply
fire in smoke in the shape of a dragon
or even the right comment while others
believe that bran saw a real dragon in
the sky so basically what we got here
are rumors rumor among small folk that
spring star heated by the breath of a
dragon as sleeps being the castle which
originates from another rumoured Educare
Solarian dream vormax left eggs have
inter fell down into crypts and she
carries spin north to get the Starks to
support his matter in era during the
dance of the Dragons the fact that means
to writing the world of Ice and Fire
dismisses the presence of dragon eggs at
Winterfell means that there probably are
eggs some interval hatched or unhatched
by this theory there are still eggs or
an egg in the crypt somewhere waiting to
be found for an egg left in the crypt
hatch and the dragon has been under the
castle ever since and in this case the
idea is that the hot springs heated the
egg to the point where it would hatch
rather than the other theory of the
dragon being the source of the hot
springs what we know for sure is that
there's at least one dragon that's been
in Winterfell for years Jon Snow himself
the ice dragon in conclusion both of
these theories that are introduced
within this very are some of the most
popular theories going into season 8 is
the null prophecy going to be fulfilled
or will the rumors turn into facts will
soon be revealed will the prophecy of
the drowned God racing in destroyed
Aegon Targaryen turn out to be urine who
likes to refer to himself as the champ
God destroying Jon Snow whose real name
is Aegon Targaryen and is there a
literal drag on him interval you decide
and let me know your opinion about both
theories in the comment section down
below and as always I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see you in the next one
peace
[Music]